you
the British Museum is across full of
ancient art Egyptian art Greek art Roman
art but I'm here today to see the most
ancient art and I mean that here in this
exhibition we've got Ice Age art which
goes back as long ago as 40,000 years
this is the first time that we see art
and sculpture emerging in the
archaeological record it's the first
time that we see traces of people that
really do seem to be the same as us
today
I think I look at this lineman and it
seems like a very modern idea to me and
there's a lot of imagination
encapsulated in it hmm
it's something that doesn't exist in
nature hmm you had to invent this you
had to pre conceived it it's also made
by someone who was very experienced in
working ivory and knew exactly what they
were doing it's someone who is allowed
the time to get on and do this this is a
work which we know from experiment takes
about 400 hours to produce it's not
about physical survival per se it's not
about staving off hunger or keeping warm
it's about psychological survival and
it's about going one better and that is
a really a sign of the modern brain
getting active and there there are more
representations of a lion man aren't
there from from the lone Valley yes it
has a tiny brother which is just in the
in the case there and we've got two
little sculptures one the tiny little
lion man just here and up above it this
wonderful depiction of a water bird it
is an interesting that the same people
effectively producing these different
images one which is quite naturalistic
and then this other one the Lion Man
which is which is so imaginary yeah
fantastic event and then this is
incredibly exciting yeah oh yes I mean
the the flutes to to put thoughts into
notation to have symbols as sound is
fantastic
that usually the flutes are made of swan
bones which which are shorter the this
one is made on the wing bone of a
Griffon vulture which gives you a longer
flute with more finger holes and you can
vary the notation these German thinks I
mean this is the first evidence that we
have of music I mean this is this is it
these piggies my always you have a song
to one yeah but to to make music using
an instrument this is these are the
oldest known instruments in the world
that we know of all these pieces of
artwork in these and these flutes
they're going along with a new
technology which is arriving in Europe
and they're going along with actually
the first wave of modern humans to come
into Europe the Neanderthals have been
there for hundreds of thousands of years
but I've never made anything like this
yeah but this is us yeah this is us this
is definitely ask
you
here come the girls and I'm particularly
pleased that we've managed to get a
broad spectrum of them to show how they
vary across Europe but also how they
show women in all different stages in
their life this this lady here who's
actually giving birth in a kneeling
position you can see her abdomen low and
and ready to to give birth and if you
turn it upside down you can see that the
baby's head is about to crown so but
also to notice how much these figures
contrast with this group here which are
from the sides of mult R Y over in
Siberia down by Lake Baikal
but she looks to me like she's wearing I
didn't know her little jackets and
trousers and she's got a little hit on
as well yeah she's well wrapped up in in
the furs because they kept me coming up
to 20,000 years ago we're coming up to
the most horrendous time as far as
climate is concerned we hear the peak of
the last ice age yeah and these people
are living in Siberia the pjo state yeah
it does seem to be something of a
conundrum here something of a paradox
because we know that biologically humans
as a species appeared perhaps even as
long ago as 200,000 years ago and we
have these kind of tantalizing glimpses
of art popping up in Africa we have
ochre crayons but we've no idea what
they were actually doing with them and
then it takes until 40,000 years ago to
actually see this this type of art is it
just that we've been looking in Europe
for longer than anywhere else is that
why we're finding more art here or do
you think there's something really
special going on in this environment I
think there is something really special
going on in this environment and yes we
have been looking in Europe a lot longer
than in other parts of the world but of
course archaeological research in
southern Africa has been going on for a
century so what we're looking at in
Europe is something distinct and rather
special
you